Porcia is in Baton Rouge hi Portia how
are you I'm good
um thanks for taking my call true well
my problem is I've been married eight
years and since the beginning of my
marriage we have been financially
supporting my mother-in-law whether it
be her electric bill didn't cut off food
whatever so we can leave she quit her
job and all the siblings are splitting
her mortgage now I said they need to
have a talk with her about getting the
job and being able to support ourselves
my husband thinks that because it's only
2% of our monthly income that I'm being
cheap so I don't know how much money
does he give her we get about 250 a
month because he won't talk to his mom
about his misbehavior I think he's
chicken
see that's what I was thinking yeah he's
chicken I ain't going to do with the
money this mama has been wagging the
tail of a dog for a long time hadn't she
yeah they shall shorty a jumpin this no
old brood jumps don't they know this is
crazy Dave I'm telling you they're like
are you kidding me if she could walk
there's nothing wrong with her I
couldn't eat you would why would you
wonder why gives her money it exactly
she doesn't have any problems y'all need
to help her have some problems
listen I'm being mean but let's let's
think it through for a minute okay
what's happening here from what a
psychologist my friend Henry cloud would
say that you all are enabling her which
means you're giving a drunk a drink
that's really what I find it has nothing
to do with the amount of money or
whether it's a strain on you I'm
thinking about her what is good for her
well she feels like it's good for her to
get all this free money from her kids
and like somehow she's got twisted in
her mind she's deserving of that but the
truth of the matter is she doesn't have
any dignity because she doesn't have any
discipline in her life she has no
control in her life and she's not
productive
she sits on her butt and it's not good
for her what would be best for her would
be if she had her own life and she had
her own dignity and she was paying her
bills and she had a career that was
fulfilling that she worked hard at and
she was saving money for retire
and she took care of business she would
feel so much better about herself
because she'd be so much better a person
and they're not helping her become that
person because she stays drunk all the
time because they give her a drink every
time she has for it metaphorically
speaking so how old is this young lady
please 66 66 what okay well she's
getting to where I'm gonna be a lot
longer she's going to be doing a lot
that's productive I mean you can't I'm
not saying people can't but how we're
talking about a 56 year old but I think
the thing is it's good for all of them
to sit down talk with her she does
something to contribute to this not sits
out there like a queen bee and everybody
brings your honey it's just a bad plan
it's not good for her dignity and it's
not good mental health and this toxic
family so yeah I think your husband has
to do something here but I don't think
he will I think he's chicken [ __ ] hold
on I'm going to give you a copy of the
book boundaries for him he needs them
and I value a lot to get a case of them
for the whole family this is the Dave
Ramsey show hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]